down
what's with the jeans kind of makes you
go and what I want to do is for us to
come one I like that a lot
you do and she's so inquisitive what I
want to know is and what I want to do is
down yeah where's the comm tom yeah and
I'll tell you just to make sure I
watched that video oh just a vet it
probably finds a bunch of it yeah a lot
of it was hiding he's hiding guys balls
and jacks and then she finds it
yeah even had I made sure blue man you
checked it out what did you see yes you
found it right she's on the couch balls
mother's old text and I love second cup
and what I want to do is worse to come
that's the long version oh oh because I
was confused yeah I'm glad it's
contextualized thing yeah yeah yeah and
well I'm just happy that she found it I
mean it sounds like I need to know
anything hey when young girls are lost
like that yeah um where's that--what's
that clip were the guys like oh those
balls full of cum I was coming those
balls who's that that's a guy that
picked up a camera one addicted
prostitute male prostitute right it's a
question if there's kind of the money
he's like oh you guys you got a
beautiful then he come in those balls is
that that new york' yeah you got any
come in those balls okay like
uncircumcised guys as I recall right
yeah yeah very cool
yeah I like redheads redheads blonde
pretty quote from close doing blonde
that's not close at all it's not close
that's why we hang out a little bit
there's so much money do you want
now how much can you give it
thirty
okay come on I wouldn't even talk to
that guy for $30 let alone suck his dick
how about how much can you give me 20
I'd be like all right man I gotta go
what's time cigarettes what's the time
segura blowjob worth you know you know
that's the thing he's good he's letting
his dick get sucked
oh right why bought dudes want that for
free that's not only good yeah but this
guy wants to suck him right see a lot of
chicks are like the loud girls come up
to me yeah um after shows when they're
like how much to suck that dick sure
busy right now I'm busy Anna and then
they'll go how much you got and they're
like 20 I'm like the new like man
where's the come where's the and they
walk back to this place I never come to
come on invite it and don't worry about
that
Paradis
tastes good so you got any come in those
balls you know whatever reminds me I was
like for some reason I think of like a
deli like that's the guy that works
behind the deli you want pastrami
you got any coming those balls you want
a cherry cola and coming your balls
it's like it's that that accent is not
sexy no that kind of context it's not
you know it's not good
you gotta come in your balls you got any
come in those balls yeah it's like it's
not right
we got a turkey on rye yeah exactly
looking for a guy with coming in balls
right yeah hey southern hey y'all you
got any coming your balls like that's
kind of a nicer different roll tab that
um this guy hey yeah he just sounds
grimy yeah it's a rut it's a rough yeah
it's a harsh or accent for sure you got
any coming those balls
that's like your uncle IRA yeah what'd
he do off on the ferris wheel babe